sur ces 8 entre 1h30 et 6h30 du matin il
y as voyages au bout de la démarche donc
ce soir une émission culturelle ou des
intervenants viennent lire un livre
voilà moi c'est mon bonheur tous les
soirs je n'en est pas une et cette
semaine on a vu un gars très sympa mais
qui galère un peu à lire on dirait
qu'ils le même prof de lecture que jean
michel mr regarder et considérer le
jugement d'une comme infaillible est
cependant y trouver l'autre ils
répondirent yop irréprochable dans les
volets toujours clos c'est renée c'est
rue sans s'égrener de pourriture sans
doute ce qui ce qu'avait plus et ses
anciennes camarades du couvent tandis
que les bannettes d'arbustes de
rhododendrons et lui avait répondu d'un
ace
ainsi colère avec un sourire que mon
frein de la bofa cite que la bonne
famille ni si fo a plu
mais qu'a bien pour la déco que jeune
homme il ne fout il est très tard et moi
mais pas les rues je sais même pas ce
qu'il disait d'ailleurs quelques lignes
des mots paris c'était ben il faut citer
l'assommoir encore une fois madame
bovary de gustave flaubert emma bovary
emma bovary ch'tis hopley emma bovary
d'ailleurs gelé ici emma bovary
à y regarder gustave flaubert alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous lire un
passage de jean michel c'est quoi vous
avez ouvert un passage pendant 15
secondes on va voir si vous partiez ou
pas l'animal est oui mais je voyais un
ba oui il est menacé par abba cissé un
peu grave mais c'était le bruit d'une
allumette keim a frotté afin de re
allumé la lampe mais n'en était de ses
lectures comme de ses tapisseries qui
tout commence et encombrer son armoire
elle les prenais des kits et passer à
d'autres elle avait des accès au cul cul
et en culture alors c'est pas ça mais
non non non c'est pas ça l avait d accès
ou ça et berlin elle avait d accès ou l'
onu a voulu pousser pour sa part on ne
produit poussé béthune et qu'on voit la
maladie vient de sortir dé lyon recevra
gustave flaubert
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
berhanu boire jusqu'à une gare big up a
toi héros alors gens l'adorent dans
cette émission c'est quand le gars
termine l'émission il sait jamais
comment dire aurevoir regarder après le
dîner le bout des trucs qui digère
et je vous dis à la prochaine fois pour
la suite
[Musique]
nous allons lire la suite la prochaine
fois à bientôt
et je m'arrête là je vous lirai la suite
pour la prochaine fois
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée à la
prochaine
[Musique]
voilà c'était la dernière pour moi et
j'espère que ma lecture nous a plu et je
vous dis à bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]
rob raté et j'ai juste une question
fatidique pour savoir ces gens là je te
plains plus arrêter excellent appel
m'appeler vous m'appelez pas à l'élite
est l'esprit de ces gens là sont au son
des gens enfin connu pas que de la
chaîne comme qui arrive le comédien
j'imagine soit non même si aulas il
fonde horde et font la demande
et puis ils sont passés nous n'importe
qui me furent seulement at on n'apprend
pas d'accord doit bâtir d'ailleurs vous
n'allez pas vous les voyez pas lire
anniversaire prochaine non ce jour merci
moi ces billets cb merci pas griller si
ces pays assez payé pour vous payer
vraiment si vous l'avez fait j'étais
payée à merde qu'est ce qu'un concours
c'est un conte na waie